then you're going to be extraordinarily  tempted  to  co-opt the force of the scientific  endeavor as a justification for your  political ambitions it's very difficult  for people to separate those sorts of  things out like i believe personally i  believe this  is that  it's very very probable to me that  massive  solutions to the climate change problem  like global scale solutions even  national scale solutions are going to  cause far more trouble than the problem  itself will cause i really believe that  of course so yeah no i don't think  there's any question about that i mean i  learned that again when i was 20 years  old and i went to the cancun climate  summit and i watched ted turner proposed  china's one child policy to thunderous  applause everyone had flown into cancun  they hadn't heard of skype  i was there  i was there and i said oh you know what  for me that's when i stopped trying to  feign being a centrist i said